من مستشفى شهداء الاقصى في دير البلح رئيس
قسم الطوارئ والمتحدث باسم مستشفى شهداء
الاقصى الدكتور خليل القران اهلا بك دكتور
خليل كيف يبدو الوضع في محيط
المستشفى ساعه ونص اختي الكريمه
لليوم وواحد على التوالي مع استمرار
الدوان الصهيوني الغاشم على ابناء شعبنا
في قطاع غزه وقصف المواطنين وهم امنين في
اماكن شفناهم الوضع الصحي في داخل هذا
المستشفى وضع كارث بمعنى الكلمه
لان القصف ايضا المحيط في بجوار في
المناطق المحيطه في هذا المستشفى يعيق عق
عمل الطواقم الطبيه ويؤثر بالرعب الكبير
لدى المصابين وايضا ناهيك على ان المستشفى
الان المنظومه الصحيه بشبه انهيار كامل
لعدم وجود مستلزمات طبيه وعدم وجود ادويه
كافيه ل لانقاذ حياه هؤلاء المصابين
واليوم وصل عدد
من المصابين الى المستشفى
واقمنا بالعمل معهم بشكل متواضع جدا وايضا
وصل عدد من الشهداء منهم شهداء اعداد منهم
وصلت متحلله وللاسف وصلت عبر كارات عبل
عبر كارات يعني اكرمكم الله تقودها
الحيوانات وهذا لعدم قدره سيارات الاسعاف
للوصول الى اماكن الشهداء بسبب استمرار
انقطاع وسائل الاتصال والتواصل ما يعني
منذ اربعه ايام
في المنطقه الوسطى وفي قطاع غزه وهذا يعيق
اتصال المواطنين الى سيارات الاسعاف ل
انقاذ حياه هؤلاء المصابين من اثار
الاستهداف في او اماكن الاستهداف من قبل
طائرات الاحتلال في
المناطق المحافظه الوسطى وهذا ينذر بخ خطر
كبير يعني ان الاصابات الموجوده من في في
اماكن الاستهداف يعني ت تترك في اماكن
الاستهداف تحت الركام تنزف حتى الموت بسبب
عدم قدره الاتصال والتواصل ما بين
المواطنين وسيارات الاسعاف وال الوضع في
داخل المستشفى ينذر يعني بكارثه صحيه اي
كما اسلفت لعدم وجود ادويه كافيه وعدم
وجود مستلزمات طبيه في داخل هذا المستشفى
نهيك عن ان منذ اول
امس نفذ الوقود في هذا المستشفى وتوقف
العمل في المستشفى وخاصه في الاقسام
الخطيره جدا مثل اقسام العنايه المكثفه
واقسام قسم العمليات واقسام الحضانه
واقسام الكيا الصناعيه وبعد
ذلك وصل يعني كميه بسيطه من الوقود الى
هذا المستشفى والان ايضا
يكاد ان ينفذ هذا الوقود وال الوضع خطير
جدا اذا استمر نفاذ الوقود وخاصه ان
المستشفى هو يوجد لدينا مولد وحيد في
المستشفى وهذا المستشفى للاسف لا يوجد
غيره في المحافظه المستشفى وهو المستشفى
الوحيد الموجود في المحافظه الوسطى طيب
دكتور خليل هذا فيما يتعلق ب الاحتياجات
والنقص داخل المستشفى في ظل استمرار القصف
ولكن اعود بك فقط لنقطه البدايه فيما
يتعلق بالقصف المستمر في محيط المستشفى هل
لديكم مخاوف من تكرار سيناريو ما حدث لعدد
من المستشفيات في شمال قطاع غزه عندما كان
القصف يكون في المحيط ويقترب اكثر حتى
يصيب داخل المستشفى
ويحاصر هذا صحيح اختي الكريمه هناك ما زال
قصف يعني موجود في
في المناطق المحيطه في المستشفى وقبل عده
ايام قصف منزل قريب على بوابه هذا
المستشفى واصاب عدد كبير من المواطنين
واصاب ايضا عدد كبير من الواقف الطبيه
واستشهد عدد كبير وهذا ايضا هناك بعض
المخاوف لدى المصابين في داخل المستشفى
والطواقم الطبيه ايضا لان ينذر بالخطر
لاستهداف المناطق المجاوره والملاصقة
الكريمه ينذر بالخطر الكبير
للطواقم الطبيه وا ايضا الهلع يزداد بين
المرضى وهذا يعيق عملنا في داخل المستشفى
نهيك على ان ايضا وسائل الاتصال والتواصل
اقدم جيش الاحتلال منذ اربعه ايام بقطع
جميع وسائل الاتصال والتواصل ما بين
المواطنين
وا المستشفى وسيارات الاسعاف وهذا ينذر
كارثه ويعني ياتي في اطار اباده جماعيه
لابناء شعبنا من في اثار استهدافهم في
اماكن الاستهداف من قبل طائرات الاحتلال
وهذا
يعيق الاتصال والتواصل ما بين سيارات
الاسعاف والمواطنين لانقاذ حياه هؤلاء
المصابين لربما هذه التقطعات في الاتصالات
باتت واضحه الان وانت معنا في البث
المباشر هناك تقطع في الصوت والصوره دكتور
خليل فيما يتعلق بالنقص الذي بتتم تواجهون
الان هل بات يؤثر ايضا على قراراتكم
وبروتوكولات العلاج التي تتبعونها سواء
للمرضى او
الجرحى هذا صحيح نحن منذ بدايه هذا
العدوان ونحن ناشدنا العالم وناشدنا
المجتمع الدولي والمنظمات الدوليه والامه
العربيه والاسلاميه وجميع العالم الحر
بامداد وتقديم المساعدات
لمستشفيات مستشفى شهداء الاقصى وخاصه هو
المستشفى الوحيد في المحافظه الوسطى وجميع
مستشفيات قطاع غزه لان حوالي لاكثر من 70%
من مستشفيات قطاع غزه خرجت عن الخدمه
والان مستشفى شهداء الاقصى وهو المستشفى
الوحيد في المحافظه الوسطى على ابواب
انتهاء الخدمه يعني خروجه عن الخدمه
الصحيه لا ابناء شعبنا في المحافظه الوسطى
وهذا ينذر بكارثه صحيه وكارثه بيئيه ولذلك
نحن ناشدنا العالم وما زد عبر قناتكم
الموقره وناشد جميع الاحرار والمنظمات
الدوليه والامه العربيه والاسلاميه
والاحرار في العالم
لامداد مستشفيات قطاع غزه وخاصه هذا
المستشفى بالمستلزمات الطبيه والادويه
والوقود لان اذا ايضا نفذ هذا الوقود يعني
ممكن ان ينفذ خلال انتهاء هذا اليوم او
غدا اذا لم يستمر يعني امداد المستشفى
بالوقود وهذا ينظر يعني بفتح مقابر جماعيه
وخاصه لمرضى العنايه المكثفه والحضانه
واقسام الكلى وغرف العمليات ولذلك انا
اناشد قبل حصول يعني او وصول للخطر الكبير
ودفن هؤلاء المرضى في مقابر جماعيه وانقاذ
حياتهم بامداد المستشفى بالمساعدات الطبيه
والادويه والمستلزمات الطبيه والوقود لعدم
وجود
ايه يعني عدم وجود وصولنا الى كارثه صحيه
وكارثه بيئيه في هذا المستشفى وقد اذا
استمر لعده ايام عدم وصول المساعدات
قد هذا المستشفى يخرج عن الخدمه الصحيه
لمصابين وللمرضى ك الله في العون نشكرك
جزيل الشكر من مستشفى شهداء الاقصى في دير
البلح رئيس قسم الطوارئ والمتحدث باسم
مستشفى شهداء الاقصى الدكتور خليل
الدقراني